what's going on guys whether you're a
Marvel fanatic or you're kind of tired
of dudes and capes and cowls you can't
deny that season one of daredevil on
Netflix was a smash success
now that we've had time to overanalyze
the show it's time to check out some of
the clues daredevil dropped about season
2 and connections to the MCU so tune in
your sonar sense because today we're
going inside daredevil season 1 to help
us go super in-depth we're going to be
using the Nvidia shield and it's 4k
streaming capabilities perfect for
catching all the details and your
favorite Netflix shows the shield can
deliver pictures so clear even Matt
Murdock would be impressed
I'm sorry daredevil please don't hurt me
let's start off with the obvious Marvel
hasn't been shy about Daredevils
connection with the movie universe heck
they even dropped Avengers tower into
their promotional motion poster but they
also snuck in some little nods for the
fans to find Ben Urich so office at the
New York bulletin contains multiple
references to previous Marvel films
including the Chitauri attack on New
York from The Avengers and Hulk's
rampage and Harlem from Incredible Hulk
boom battle of New York you know what
that's talking about Loki Thor the Hulk
yeah that thing and boom Harlem terror
that's talking about the Hulk not Bill
Clinton when kingpin unleashes an
all-out war on Hell's Kitchen
the first news team to the scene whi H
fictional network that apparently chases
superheroes kind of like lawyers chase
ambulances again apologies to the law
firm of Nelson and Murdock whi H has
been prominently featured in several
Marvel projects including coverage of
the Hulk's rampage at Culver University
in the Incredible Hulk we also hear
references to the Roxxon corporation an
evil conglomerate that's been referenced
in multiple Iron Man movies
and in the TV show agents of shield not
only does my client Roxxon Energy
Corporation categorically deny any
culpability
speaking of agents of shield daredevil
has direct connections with two
characters from their Marvel TV sister
show Matt Murdock's father is killed for
not throwing a boxing match against Carl
the crusher creel this characters also
known as the absorbing man and actually
appeared in the rapidly mutating flesh
in season two of agents of shield bonus
fact there's also a poster promoting a
fighter named Barton who happens to
share the last name of an Avenger who
you might say has a hawk's eye Hawkeye
talking about honking there's also tied
as shields expert hacker and resident
inhuman Skye both she and Matt Murdock
grew up in the same orphanage Saint
Agnes
huh I wonder if they were snuck into
each other's rooms and played I'll show
you my power if you show me yours of
course the mother of all Easter eggs is
an appearance by the man himself Stanley
he's been in every MCU movie today and
many were surprised they didn't appear
in daredevil well he did he's right
there in the background of the police
station as a I guess some kind of
Employee of the Month
hey Stan Excelsior to you the show
doesn't just offer up a wink and a nod
to its brothers in arms of Marvel though
it drops a few significant hints about
characters that we know or heavily
suspect will appear in season 2 first
off elektra natchios Daredevils vengeful
Greek sometimes enemy sometimes
girlfriend you don't see any hints about
Electress future in the show though
foggy does drop oh pretty significant
reference you trying to tell me that you
didn't take Spanish to snuggle up to
what's-her-name the duh the Greek girl
or maybe he's just talking about some
random failed relationship with an
attractive Greek mystery woman
also hinted at is one of Daredevils
greatest enemies the ruthless assassin
bullseye when Wilson Fisk needs someone
to frame daredevil for killing a cop he
enlists this faceless sharpshooter whose
bag bears one of bull's-eyes trademarks
the ace of spades or again that could be
just some random expert marksman who
works for the kingpin and his fond of
that particular
playing-card probably a big blackjack
player maybe a Texas Hold'em guy but I
doubt it one character we absolutely
know will be in season two is Frank
Castle The Punisher played by Walking
Dead's Jon Bernthal Shane he's hinted at
very subtly with this truck bearing the
name of Somerville department stores a
reference to an employer of his from one
specific issue of the Punisher comic
book or I mean it could just be another
Somerville at you know what no no way
that one's definitely on purpose and
finally one last little tidbit
definitively opens the door for
daredevil to appear in the upcoming
Captain America Civil War oh look at
that sign right there behind Matt
Murdock in the police station you don't
have to reveal your identity to help
solve Violent Crimes ah that's exactly
the plot of the comic book storyline
superheroes revealing their secret
identities to quell public unrest about
superhero violence and guess who shows
up fighting alongside Captain America
daredevil okay yeah it was an easter egg
we don't have to be Tony Stark to figure
that one out
so is your favorite daredevil Easter Egg
there were tons more of them that
internet the hand steel serpent the
chaste crane mother and a bunch more
comic book stuff that I frankly need to
catch up on leave us a comment below let
us know what the coolest Easter Egg was
and best comment we're gonna send you a
screen junkies t-shirt I want to thank
the Nvidia shield for powering this
episode with 4k streaming I'm Hal
Rudnick I wanna thank you for watching
hit me up on Twitter bye bye how close
are we to the government actually
militarizing raptors well I would say
we're very far given that we don't have
actress yeah we don't have Raptors so
completely implausibly far